Let's come to the point now since your
Quran tells me to judge my by my Bible.
Stop the tap dance. Tell me corrupt. Now
let's go to the Bible and have the
discussion on Jesus being God. Can we
get back to that point now? Yeah, we can
go back to that. But now before we do
that, okay, I'll let you say something.
But before you do that, in 7157, it says
there's a prophecy of your umi prophet
in the gospel that was with them. You
said that gospel is Matthew, Mark, Luke,
and John. Where is that prophecy in
Matthew, Mark, Luke, and John? I don't
want us to to to to be running in
different topics. No, it's okay because
we come back to Jesus being God. That's
why I'm proving Jesus is God because I
would love to hear if any Christian can
tell me Jesus is God. And yeah, very
easy. Can I show you? Yeah, sure. Show
me. Surah Hajj. Read for me. I'm gonna
show you, but read Hajj. I'm gonna go to
the Bible, but I want you to now tell me
some about your God because I'm gonna
show you Jesus claimed to be your God in
surah Hajj 226 and 7. What does Allah
do?
He does that. Get your Gospel of John
ready. John chapter 5. Okay. Okay. And
then after
read for me 226 and 7. Yeah. I'm saying
do you want the Arabic? I should recite
the Arabic or the English. Read slowly
Arabic. It's okay. You can read English.
That's fine. But I want to ask you about
because you said I heard you. So you
believe in
you believe. Yeah.
Yeah. Let melim what you believe.
Brother, be patient. Let me make my
point so they can know what you believe.
You believe in.
Okay. Now read 22 6 and 7 in English.
Every time they want to get out of the
hellfire from angel, go to 226 and 7
because I'm going to use the gospel of
John to show Jesus is Muhammad's God.
Just read the ayat.
That is because Allah is the true
reality and because he gives life to
death and because he is over all things
competent and that they may know the
hour is coming, no doubt about it and
that Allah will resurrect those in the
graves. Okay. So, one of the names of
Allah's Alhak, which your translation
said true reality, which means the
truth. Alak. Yeah. According I want to
see how honest you are. If you say Allah
is honest, then you're going to be
honest. According to Alma,
can anyone call himself alth?
In what sense?
Stop playing the game before I now bring
you Abu Amina Bilal Phillips and I'm
going to have him then educate. Don't
tell me what sense. Alak the truth is it
one of the 99 names of Allah.
Yeah. Okay. Can you give any of the 99
names of Allah to a creature?
Yeah. So you can give it to them like
you are a liar. I'm going to show you.
Show me in the Quran where anyone other
than the Allah is called alak. Give it
to me. Not I have you asked me about
attribute any of the names right? No I
said the 19 names of Allah
the do you want me to show you where a
creation can be name after I'm going to
show you that you're a mushri like your
god. So let me ask you the question
again. Al hak you're playing games
because you're scared. No I'm not
scared. 99 names of Allah. What is
alashat? Let now let you define it
because you just contradict yourself.
Explain to us.
Explain it. Okay. To believe that Allah
has some asma orat names and somehat.
No, it's more than that. What does that
mean?
Don't play games with me. I know your
dean better than you. So, explain it. I
don't think you know my dean better than
me. Okay, then explain it.
Okay. I just said to believe we see we
believe in these three category of
and maybe you don't know this. Let me
teach you this. Maybe you don't know.
What does that mean? Is there any other
lord besides Allah? No. Can you give to
anyone besides Allah? No. No. No. No.
You can't. To believe
in that Allah has names.
Can you give it to a creature if it's to
him?
Yeah, some you can give it to them. Some
that means you can make some you can
make some your too because
and others are. No. Now I'm going to ask
you show me in your Quran one place
where someone other than Allah is called
alak. Go ahead.
But you are say I say wrote for me one
place where someone other than Allah is
called alhak. I'm going to give you two
minutes. Yes. There is no such place in
the Quran. Say it again. There's no such
place in the Quran. A second challenge
to see how honest you are. If you're
more honest than your God, can you show
me anywhere in your Quran where someone
other than Allah will raise the dead out
of their graves?
No, there's no such verse. Say it again.
There is no such verse. Okay. So only
Allah is alhak the truth and only Allah
will raise them out of their graves at
the hour. Now read for my friend John
5:21
25. So get John five ready because now
we're going to show that Jesus claimed
to be his God. John 5 21 and 25.
Chris just to start with. Yeah I got
you. So John 5:21 says, "For as the
Father raises the dead and gives them
life, so also the Son gives life to whom
he will." Now read 25. And 25 states,
"Truly, truly I say to you, an hour is
coming and is now here, when the dead
will hear the voice of the Son of God,
and those who hear will live." Now read
28:29.
For an hour is coming when all who are
in the tombs will hear his voice and
come out. Those who have done good to
the resurrection of life and those who
have done evil to the resurrection of
judgment. So Chris, just to make sure we
we we heard you clearly, you just quoted
Jesus in John 5:21.
John 5:25
John 5 20-29 where Jesus says just as
the father raises the dead and gives
them life. So to the son gives life to
whom he wills and the hour is coming and
is now come when the dead and their
graves will hear the voice of the son of
God and come out. Right? Yes sir. And
then John 14:6 Jesus says I am the way
the truth alak and the life. No man
comes to the father except through me.
So now all of Islam, can you show me any
prophet who's a Muslim who says, "I am
the son of God and at the hour I will
raise them out of their graves at the
hour and I am the truth." Can you show
me any prophet who said that? You see,
uh, you just make me realize that I
Jesus is God. To say Jesus is God
because he resurrected life. No, that's
not what I said. No, no, no. Don't twist
my argument. I'm not gonna let you lie.
I'm not going to prophet.
I didn't say listen to my argument.
Here's what I said. Can you show me a
prophet who at the hour
will raise the dead from their graves
and who says he's the truth and the
light? Because you just said in front of
everyone, your Quran says Allah will
raise them from their graves at the
hour. And I said, does anyone else do
that? You said no. Don't twist my
argument.
Show me a prophet at the hour.
No, nobody can resurrected life without
God. That's not my argument again. All
of Islam, you're wasting my time. You're
a kid. Let me repeat my argument a third
time. You just read chapter 22 6-7 where
your Quran says Allah is the truth and
at the hour Allah meaning
Allah at that hour will raise the dead
from their graves. Jesus said at the
hour I the son of God will raise them
from their graves. I will do it because
I'm the truth and the life. Can you now
show me a prophet in your Quran who says
he's the truth and the life and he'll be
the one to raise the dead from the
graves at the hour?
Please repeat your question. I this is
okay. One more time before I lose my
voice because I got to teach. You just
read chapter 22
6 and 7. Let me remind you what you
read. Yeah, you read it says Allah is
the true reality, al the truth, and he
gives life to the dead. And then it says
the hour is coming. Notice the hour is
coming. Have no doubt about it. When
Allah will raise them from the graves.
Okay? Then I asked you, does anyone else
do this besides Allah? He said, no, only
Allah. We just read Jesus in John. Let
me repeat what Jesus said. The hour is
coming. same hour
same hour he says I the son of God will
raise them from the graves by my voice
because he is the truth and the life. So
can you show me a prophet that does what
the Quran says Allah does at the hour
like Jesus just claimed.
We don't have such in the Quran. Then
please allow me to explain. Okay. Is
Jesus a good Muslim?
Yeah, he is a Muslim. So why did Jesus
just claim to do what your Quran says
Allah will do at that hour? No, this is
what we found. John said that Jesus said
we don't have you agreed with me. 54647
says I can judge by my Yeah. If John
copy something which is somehow similar
with what is in the Quran. Wow. John
came before the Quran. No answer. How
could he copy what's in the Quran when
the Quran comes later?
Yeah, we don't know. But what I'm saying
if if he said something which is similar
and and and it's exact if it is if it is
exact but
but this is what John told us. Jesus
said
I want you to I want you to thank
yourself. You buried yourself because
now when you question John, you're
admitting that what John said, Jesus
says, Jesus claimed to be God. Thank you
for helping me destroy your dean.
Because now you have to say the Bible's
corrupt.
Thank you for bearing